oh your mama was a feminist yes and she
tried to install that programming into
you she did did you accept it or reject
it well I dab and along with them
growing up like I was saying I was you
know born 1980 and then being a teenager
in the 90s Madonna and you know all of
that Material Girl yeah and the material
world yeah um yeah when along with that
and then you know someone mentioned Neo
independent woman you know the music is
huge yeah Carmen mentioned that had a
huge impact and uh yeah I thought that
was the the the right way so I worked
hard I mean
literally my 20s I worked like 78 hours
a week I loved my job absolutely loved
it
um and then
I did settle down with the guy but I
didn't get married because that wasn't a
value like my mum was like don't worry
about getting married do I have kids
just live your life maybe so your mom
was like yeah just go out there get
money and live your movie yeah
so like how do you feel about that now
um
do you feel like she Mouse did you in
the wrong direction
um
you can be real man she's not here it's
okay
no I love my mom and you know she's a
you can love your mom but your mom still
can be wrong you know yeah absolutely
and I do tell her that every day bless
her no if you had your time again would
you no I would um
I would get married I would have gotten
married
um
yeah stayed married and stayed married
would you have marriage I was with my
daughter's dad for about 12 years
um do you think he should have been your
husband
you know like in the beginning like when
he mentioned marriage I thought I don't
want to get married forget that like oh
snap yeah and um I never really
understood like the the value in getting
married but I think like actually giving
your word giving your word that you are
going to stick with this person
I think that will make a bigger
difference in actually making it work do
you think do you would you agree that a
lot of times a lot of older women give
younger women bad advice 100
I think it just depends on like you said
the programming what programming did
that older woman received what kind of
software exactly so if you if you've got
the corrupt if you've got the malware
corrupt your hand down malware you know
like that if you get if you come from a
two-parent household then you're more
likely to still get you should come you
should a two parent household should
come from you because you came from a
two-part household but if you come from
a single parent household and it's the
mum saying yeah well I would had to work
two free jobs so I don't maybe they're
saying they don't want that for her but
for their child yeah but but the reason
is that that men are bad in it like you
can't find a good man basically I'm like
my dad wasn't the best I loved him like
to me he did his best but as a husband
and how he
treated my mom in certain ways but I
also you know think a lot of women don't
take responsibility for
their part they don't see the
psychological abuse they just don't see
it like constantly making a man wrong
like the way
but women can make a man feel like
is women don't really see that so yeah
what do you think about you know
feminism what do you think about it
though I think it's set us back
like way back and the way that
oh don't get me started
way back I think what I what I noticed
in like when I really look at like the
society and the media especially like if
you notice a lot of media kind of it
kind of installed that programming as
well because like for instance when you
watch like a lot even cartoons you might
watch The Simpsons or Family Guy the dad
is always like an idiot he's always like
a fumbling and the mom has to be the one
controlled one that's level-headed where
the where the dad is just like an idiot
and you know it's subtle but it it's
actually quite significant because
everybody watches The Simpsons everyone
watches and it's just like yeah I think
that Society um the media it really
pushes for like you know men are
incapable women have to take the the
Reigns of everything can like girl power
kind of thing what do you not think
about it what's the consequences of it
was the consequences of it men are
emasculated yeah men are masculated
women or women are not to say women
shouldn't feel like you know they can
make decisions yeah but at the end of
the day most women will want a man that
is a leader a man that is competent a
man that is confident the man that you
know she can rely on and look to you
know in times of need where they don't
want to they don't want to couple up
with Homer Simpson they don't want to
couple up with Peter Griffin
I was saying that earlier sorry how do
you think we can change the situation I
think it's every man's Duty personally
to be the best version of himself I
think that every man should uh strive to
get financial power physical power you
know be you know in best physical shape
he can yeah mental power he cannot
afford to be ignorant you just can't bro
like and as women we have to empower
those men because I I just talk to women
a lot and I'm like you talk so much
about men how do you expect to meet a
nice man The Law of Attraction you know
and um the other thing is
um
sorry I lost mobile production I saw
power coming in I lost my um
especially because she called me bass
thank you thank you thank you it was a
quick statement
okay
this is what I was gonna say how we how
we how what we do about it let's get
shut down please let's get a little
round of applause thank you for King
riches yeah
and you're the one she was uh telling
you why you're not smiling do you
remember that's why he wasn't she was so
desperate for a long time
what were you guys talking about
um we were saying like how so you know
the situational with feminism
demasculated like a guy was saying so
like what do we do about that and I'm
like you're shutting down people like
that like like exactly like
stop like women talking about men
is going on and on and on and I just
shut it down as much as I can and yeah
sometimes I do get into arguments with
my girlfriends but so what did you did
your mom do that to you because you said
you said your mom was a feminist did you
talk about me yeah yeah I I yeah I
shot her down immediately when was your
like red pill moment that switched is
that no because I I'd imagine at some
point like I mean if she was talking
like this when you were a kid you kind
of believe what your parents say for a
while yeah yeah absolutely but um it was
in my relationship
um when I was having arguments with my
ex-partner it was like I could just
afterwards I was like those were not my
opinions it's like I can hear my mom's
voice in my head but like I said it got
to a point where it kind of got a bit
too late to to be able to like save that
relationship it just got to a point it
could have gotten abusive from both
sides
um but yeah that it was it was
not that long ago
um and one of the questions I was going
to ask you like what what would you do
now to like compete for a guy compete
yeah I mean it's always that love is a
competition you don't think
what would I do to compete
that's a good question what does that
mean yeah like okay
would you agree that most women go for
the same types of guys
yeah in in terms of there's a list of
things that women want and there's only
a small percentage of men that fit that
that have good enough jobs that are good
enough looking that are tall enough
there's not enough men that we want to
go around there's enough men to go
around but not that that women
I would um
I am starting to learn to listen
to the man and shut my mouth a bit more
finding it difficult I'm not succeeding
every time so but that's yeah that's
what I would really take on is is to be
a lot more feminine now because I did
take on being a masculine and
you're an athlete though right okay and
my GP things like my testosterone is
high so no I think it's a thing I can
like tell when women play sports like
from a young age I don't know what it is
but it's like I can because you're an
athlete no no I it's me too but I'm like
I think I've heard it imbalances or
hormones it does that's what my my
doctor was saying well all the sports
you're doing and all this is not helping
really what did he say I'm so curious
that's what he said it goes that my
testimony it's hard and he said and I
was doing like kickboxing at some point
he was like well that's not gonna help
you be feminine why don't you start
dancing
I actually really yes thank you I really
want to start dancing yeah and um yes I
will get in touch with you about that
let's do it because my coordination when
it comes to dancing with this crap if
you play football you already you must
have yeah
I'm in the same way
I'm like what are they doing like I
can't do like what's the coordination is
so different than sport I know exactly
what you're talking about
I mean I wasn't soccer I couldn't do the
feet we call it football here I'm sorry
I can't soccer to me it's okay yes so uh
yeah I would uh compete in yeah keeping
myself fit I'm in my 40s now so I can't
afford to let myself go
um yeah keep myself fit and really like
being more submissive and feminine
because
um yeah do you think you could be in the
top one percent of listeners to keep the
man that you're saying yeah let's go for
that mate do you have you ever like
sought out to learn certain skills um
for a guy
so like cooking cleaning I don't know my
ex taught me how to cook okay and cheese
yeah have you ever thought about
reconciling could you ever
um no I don't
I is he still single
it might be now I don't want to talk
about his businesses okay okay yeah but
um no I think of it past that we get on
we get on but
um
I can't get into like the personal stuff
but they're they're um
no there are certain differences that
uh
I can't it's not by choice there are
certain things that just can't okay what
about the guys have you ever sought out
to learn a certain skill to get women
not really no the women always just came
to you I think just before you fall in
place
what with me I mean for me women fall in
place so don't need to
you know really learn anything yeah we
all right look how tall you are you're
all right
you're nice when I was like late teens
early 20s now it's like that cool like I
need to make sure I've got a job so I
have a little bit of money so I can say
okay let's go to the cinema or something
I need to I was working out a lot more
because it's like okay what no girl I
want no fat guy I'm already short so
like let me try and work on those loads
of things I try to work on to be
but there's those things I try to work
on to try and be more appealing because
I I didn't I feel like for me personally
there was a lot more to do with my
self-image where I didn't view myself as
the most attractive so yeah maybe that
came across to the women that I was
talking to at the time
um whereas now
I have a lot more self-confidence so
like I can engage in conversation more
and be more uh successful in just having
General conversations where I wasn't at
that point and I thought if I did these
things I'll be more successful when it
really just should have worked on myself
did you actively like study how to talk
to women how to approach women no no
none of that stuff I don't know if
you're a pickup guy no no but I thought
if well if I have the because I was
already fighting with like telling jokes
and stuff like that but it was just like
I felt like if I had the look if I had
the if I had a Blackberry if I had like
the right clothes if I made sure I
always had a haircut yeah like other
little things I thought I could make it
work so yeah
I think
um that I don't think there's anything
wrong with that it's all about
self-improvement at the end of the day
and um yes this worked for my benefit
man it's maybe I'll each side of myself
I didn't know I had you know book a room
confident happy within my myself I'm not
the I I don't look the ideal way I want
to look but I'm working towards it and
whilst I'm working towards it I just put
it on that guy man that's it you know I
think that's what the
the main thing is just confidence yeah
man for men in in general from your
confidence
it it doesn't matter because even today
we all came in didn't know each other it
was all sat down just talking
and everyone was able to get along
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible